[Music]
once upon a time
there was a town and all of the people
were stuck but one girl
was different i really need this job i'm
sorry
they told her you'll never leave this
place so how did she escape
are you sure
there was a game it's called panic
this year the winner's gonna take home
50 000
each year there are new players
new challenges
you don't need panic to go to college
yeah i do
you could actually win just be careful
last year this game put two of our kids
in the ground
and someone's gonna pay guys
starting
[Music]
first challenge walk the plank let the
games
every player has a story you're not
afraid everybody's afraid of something
every player is hiding something you and
me we can win this together
i think someone is trying to fix the
game
we know that the games are organized by
judges we don't really know who's
involved
tell me the truth why are you playing
you got to know what to be afraid of
to be afraid of it you gotta know the
difference
once upon a time there was a town made
of
i ain't lies no place to go
[Music]
you